what review should I do for the
Halloween special today
watch the shininess Chris come watch the
shiny
okay Wow
yeah let's watch it I mean I love that
movie let's watch it okay okay
[Music]
welcome back to the fifth annual
Halloween special and we are now talking
about my favorite horror film of all
time Stanley Kubrick's The Shining has
inspired an entire generation of
filmmakers and film lovers and multiple
generations after that and it's going to
continue to do that because it is
actually that good critics didn't quite
know what to make of this movie when it
was released it received very mixed
reviews from professionals as well as
audience members it was one of the
earliest films to have a huge star like
Jack Nicholson and be very metaphorical
and philosophical without any hard
answers it left you wondering what
exactly you just saw it was vastly
different from Stephen King's original
novel which much to King's dismay has
displeased him for years as well it was
even nominated for a Razzie award which
is just insane because this film is
basically perfect there are a few films
that I look at and think I don't
actually think there is a flaw Ridley
Scott's original alien being won Stanley
Kubrick's The Shining being another my
history with this movie is kind of
interesting because for a long time my
parents were like you can't watch that
one that one's just too much and I was
always like but I always wanted to watch
it so bad because I love horror and I
obviously like Jack Nicholson but as a
kid I remember being very frightened by
the concept of actually watching it but
it intrigued me it was one of those
films that when I eventually saw it I'm
pretty sure I hid it from my parents I
can't remember for sure the first time I
saw The Shining I believe it was on TV
in the middle of the night and I watched
it thinking I don't want to tell my
parents this if you have been watching
my reviews for a while whenever I'm in
this background you may have noticed
that I have the photograph that shows at
the very end of the shining printed
right there that photograph has caused
debate amongst film lovers for decades
what does it mean it chills me to the
bone every time I watch it because the
entire film beforehand is so unsettling
as you watch Jack Torrance and his
family get torn apart by some kind of
supernatural
presence that's in this hotel and the
whole film from beginning to end just
gives you such shiver inducing
goosebumps at that last photo makes you
feel so on edge
uneasy even because you don't know what
it means has he been there this entire
time was someone who looked like him
there before and that is the genius of
Kubrick he will show you amazing images
he will present to you an essentially
perfect film and then you leave not
knowing exactly what you just saw but
you know you want to see it again
from the opening shot of the shining
this film has some of the best
cinematography and camerawork that I've
ever had the pleasure of seeing tons of
people over the years have analyzed this
movie and tried to explain it because
that's just what we do nowadays we want
to look at something we want to figure
out exactly what it means the beauty of
the shining is that there are multiple
interpretations and that's something I
love about this film in particular is
that you can watch it you can feel that
you understand it and have a closeness
to it and then you can hear 10,000 other
theories and be like oh well that's kind
of interesting it's a film that keeps
giving and giving there's a documentary
about it called room 237 which if you
watch that as a documentary about what
the shining means it's kind of silly but
if you watch it as a documentary about
fan obsession it's rather fascinating
because a lot of the theories in that
documentary are just absurd and they
don't make any sense to me at all but if
you watch it and view it from the lens
of these are obsessed people and this is
what it does to your brain then it's
kind of interesting I mean there are
people who have made up theories about
the Apollo moon landing and that Kubrick
is admitting and apologizing for faking
the footage in this movie it's insane
just how much this film has impacted
people I got to talk about Jack
Nicholson this is in my top 10 favorite
performances ever Steven Spielberg once
mentioned the first time he saw The
Shining he thought Nicholson was really
bad and he didn't quite understand
exactly what the character was going for
or what Kubrick was going for and the
next few times Spielberg watched it he
admitted to it
fantastic performance when you first
watch Jack Nicholson in the shining it
does seem a little weird if you've never
seen the movie before because he's
almost in a comedy he's so light-hearted
in certain scenes even in the
specifically horrific ones hi Lloyd the
scenes at the bar with Lloyd are some of
my favorites of all time whenever a
friend of mine does something and I want
to thank them I'll go good man
I do it and to it all the time they're
so quotable I'd never hurt a hair on his
goddamn head I love the little son of a
bitch but as you watch his sanity
continuously break down as he's affected
by whatever this presence is at this
hotel
it's absolutely riveting leading to
another scene that is so frightening but
oddly funny as well with Jack stalking
Shelley up the stairs I'm not gonna hurt
you honey light of my life I said I'm
not gonna hurt you
I'm just gonna bash your brains in I'm
gonna bash him right the fuck in the
imagery as well is so haunting the twins
in the hallway the blood coming out of
the elevator just the tone set up by the
musical score which was also very
revolutionary one of the first musical
scores for a horror film to be mostly
noises without any real themes there's a
theme in the beginning for the most part
the score here is just a lot of
unsettling sounds tons of horror movies
since have copied off of this the entire
film from the opening to the closing
just drenches you and permeates your
soul with this crushing weight of dread
there is not a single other horror movie
that's been able to accomplish this
let's talk about Scatman Crothers as
well excellent here he understands that
young danny has this ability to shine
it's a psychic ability and he is able to
talk to him in that way and the way
Kubrick does this is it's so realistic
there's never a moment in this movie
that feel
it's become over the top despite Jack
Nicholson's humungous performance
somehow he's able to ground all of this
in reality to where you believe
everything that's happening and that's
just one reason Kubrick is such a master
he can show you some of the craziest
things some of the most over-the-top
performances like in dr. Strangelove
with Peter Sellers and you believe it
all because he keeps it real
his films feel real famously Shelley
Duvall was not treated very well on set
by Kubrick some have said it's because
he was just being an ass and others have
said that it's because he was doing that
so that she would give off a very
miserable performance whatever his
motivation was it worked she is
devastated throughout this entire movie
even in the opening scenes where shit
hasn't quite hit the fan yet and she's
talking with the doctor that's visited
her house about the past with her kid
Danny and the maybe abuse that happened
you can tell that she is just on edge
she's really great here and her
performance is underrated she often gets
hate and I don't think it's warranted
and Danny Lloyd still has given one of
the best child performances of all time
this film is the gift that keeps on
giving every time I watch it which is at
least once a year
I find myself inspired by it again it
has influenced so many filmmakers it's
influenced myself it's my favorite
horror movie of all time and of course
I'm gonna give the shining and a plus
guys thank you so much for continuing to
watch the Halloween special we have some
more stuff coming for you very soon you
guys are the best and if you like this
you can click right here and get steppen
iced
[Music]